thank you very much for coming
appreciate it I know you got a lot of
things to choose from I'm really excited
to be here today and talk to you about
privacy governance and explain ability
in ml Rai so just real quickly about
myself so I I would be remiss not to
first mention my wife Michele who with
without whom I would not be here at all
and I'm a proud cat dad so I have three
kitties velvet lacey and ginger
so if you see miss types half the time
it's me half the time it's them walking
on the keyboard interest list obviously
data privacy it's what we're here to
talk about analytics and process design
I really love merging the the softer and
skill side of things to the technical
side being that kind of bridge between
the technical challenges that we're
dealing with today and the processes
that we have to put in place to make
those possible to handle and my why so I
am a solution architect at salon
consulting and one of the really
important things about slalem is that
it's important we identify our why why
are we here why are we doing what we're
doing and my co-workers will tell you
that I incessantly want to embed privacy
into everyday processes I don't care how
much you deal with how big the
organization is I want to do it because
I truly believe that data privacy is
going to continue to be a cornerstone of
businesses and their competitive
advantage but then also from a risk
perspective when you're mitigating risk
you can put a lot of overhead in the
process you can put a lot of steps that
are unnecessary to try and get things
perfect how can we do it in a way that
doesn't stifle innovation but it still
minimizes that risk I also have the the
honour of being able lecture at UC
Berkeley and human rights and values and
data and consult with good research as
well in the privacy space before that I
was at UMSL for my undergraduate in
accounting believe it or not and Charter
Communications and Boeing prior work
experience so lots of highly regulated
areas lots of very different regulations
so it may be love the compliance side
whether I liked it or not
so today's entertainment so first I'm
gonna walk you through a brief evolution
of data privacy who here knows what
data privacy is hopefully a good amount
of you awesome well I'm gonna try and
breeze through it I just didn't want to
make any assumptions about the level of
detail here but it's important to get
that then we're going to talk about
trust context and privacy by design why
those matter and then we're gonna get
into the real reason that we're doing
this and that's to talk about the unique
challenges that live within machine
learning problems and then the methods
that we can use for both discovering
that privacy risk and then what can we
do about mitigating it I'll say that by
no means am I going to be able to run
through every possible method I'm gonna
dip into a few but would love to
continue this conversation after and
beyond
alright so brief evolution data privacy
why does it matter these are great
companies up here I by no means show
these companies because they have any
material weaknesses or problems that
need to be called out it's really to
show that even the best of businesses
can have mistakes in their processes
some are data breaches some are just
privacy violations the majority of data
breaches believe it or not are actually
well intended people who make a mistake
so it's not like we're just trying to do
security and keep people from breaching
our systems that is needed but also what
we're doing is trying to make sure that
we're using data the way that we say we
are that we're being transparent
communicating with consumers about that
and that we carry that through in
everything not just what we think is the
most important decision but every
decision that gets made throughout the
consumer lifecycle so real briefly here
this is just looking at the u.s. of
course but I wanted to cover the
landscape of privacy risk this is just
looking at 2018 believe it or not 13
different states in the u.s. actually
implemented new policies around data
privacy more than 40 actually introduced
new legislation and then one for the
federal level as well which believe it
or not companies are finally crying for
who here knows gdpr do you awesome love
it thank you it is of course the
cornerstone it's what California is
trying to mimic some level of success
but it's keeping global companies that
that that may be based in the u.s. from
acting
they're just in the u.s. so now that
it's coming stateside it's actually
bringing things together and it's
helping make that argument for holistic
compliance national regulations talked
about the u.s. but of course we have to
worry about all the other different
things that nations have some nations
have put in data residency or data
sovereignty requirements
thou shalt not send my data across
borders without permission and that's
changing how companies need to think
about hosting data whether it's on
premise or in the cloud how can they
keep things within that border and what
does that mean to how they implement
things States we've kind of already
talked about California's leading the
way but you've got New York Vermont
Nevada Colorado they're just coming
they're coming with more and they're
coming with different pieces because
every state wants to be a little bit
special but they all have very common
attributes about them and then industry
regulations there's a great deal of
overlap and privacy with things like
HIPAA or PCI your payment card
information things like that it's not
just hey am i compliant with gdpr it's
do I have a holistic privacy model that
allows me to deal with these things and
once you get to machine learning it
becomes even more complicated because
the amount of moving parts that you have
to deal with and the amount of things
that you can very succinctly define get
less and less as you go forward so just
an idea of perspectives on privacy one
thing that I really want to debunk is
that privacy is not just about security
privacy is is about both trying to
prevent the unauthorized use of data but
also how you govern the authorized use
of it so it's the entire data life cycle
it's everything from the point at which
you communicate with the consumer and
say hey would you like a quote please
provide your email in your name and
we'll be happy to service you it's
through to the end of when you're done
they say I don't want to be a customer
anymore hopefully it's 40 years later
and they just don't need the service and
then what do you do with their data and
everything in between
the lifecycle cannot be ignored so
privacy doesn't start or stop at any
individual point until that person is no
longer consumer that you're even
targeting let alone serving so thinking
about what these what these regulations
have actually given us the right to do
so fundamental right to privacy doesn't
just mean that you have the right to
have things be private it also means you
the right to know what isn't private and
why why is that you need to be able to
have the autonomy to make decisions
right I I can go into a store and I can
choose to buy something but do I know if
someone's using my personal data right
now to refine an algorithm that can
target people for something it's very
important that we're able to do that so
these new regulations get get us the
ability to ask several questions what
data are you collecting this is of
course all of these are new with the
advent of data privacy we used to be
able to go out and scrape whatever we
wanted and as long as we weren't
infringing upon patents or trademarks or
copyrights it was okay it was public we
got it from somewhere right so we can
use it no not anymore you have to be
very specific about why you're
collecting it and what you're collecting
and then once you collect it how are you
using that data consumers have the right
to know one through privacy policies you
have to proactively tell consumers what
you're doing and how you're protecting
their data because it's not just a oh
are you okay with it okay you're okay
with it I'll take it and do whatever I
want now no it's it's an ongoing life
cycle so if there's a change in business
purpose along the way then they actually
have to be made aware of that so that
they can then make that decision
oh you collected my data for this
transaction but now you want a profile
and target me I don't know if I'm okay
with that data privacy actually gives
consumers the right to make that claim
and you have to proactively let them
know they have those rights so while I
might have data in a database and I want
to go in profile things I actually have
to be very careful about whether or not
that's within the business purpose that
that consumer said yeah sure you can use
my age and my weight how long are you
keeping my data I lose track of how many
times folks say data retention I keep it
forever right it's my data you gave it
to me I keep it forever that's not okay
anymore you can't just hide behind I
know I don't have a use for it today but
I might in the future if you don't have
a reason to have that data you shouldn't
have it and now regulators are finally
getting in the middle of that and saying
okay prove to us that you said I can
keep it for this long prove to us why
that's reasonable and then show me that
you're doing it will you delete my data
if I ask this is the right to be
forgotten or the right to erasure and
GPR but it also is pervasive in
California if I find out that you have
personal information that you don't need
through business or legal purposes and I
am a resident in one of those areas I
have the right to say you know what
delete that personal information you
don't need it anymore and you have to do
it you have to do it within a reasonable
amount of time it doesn't have to be
like that but you have to do that and
you can do it through one of two ways
you can either actually delete it or you
can anonymize that data and by
anonymized I really mean it it can no
longer be tagged to you as an individual
you might be a record with a handful of
fields that get retained but it's now
been reasonably impossible to link that
back to you as a person so that if all
of that record were to be released
it wouldn't be manageable for a bad
agent to apply that back to you and then
what were you do with my data stolen
data breach has become a large thing and
I know because Equifax really actually
hit me hard and I had some folks try and
set up loans for houses after that
breach in my name so that was fun but as
a result of that that really made it
keen to me as to what businesses should
have to do whenever there is a breach
what got stolen what could be used how
do you know what are you gonna tell me
is there a way for me to figure out do I
just have to wait until I get an alert
that says a new car loans been opened in
your name or what kind of comfort can I
get because right now I'm losing trust
as a consumer and I'm feeling like
you're not upholding these things so you
have to have very specific incident
response processes defined and then you
have to have those breach notifications
defined as well because as I mentioned
before the consumer relationship is the
entire life cycle of the data it's from
the point at which you solicit that data
to the point at which you no longer have
it and everything in between so if
something bad happens it doesn't change
that relationship you still have to do
things there's still a bar that you
have to get to so trust context and
privacy by design I'll try to stay off
my high horse here but I love this so
first and foremost transparency and
consumer trust these are not buzzwords
these are not little cute words they're
very important right now
consumer data yes it's an asset it's an
asset to every business and if they're
not treating it that way they need to
because they're losing money as a result
but it can very easily become a
liability all you need to do is take it
for granted something bad happens I
don't update my security I use some
information and then it accidentally
gets posted to a public github repo I
all kinds of mistakes can happen I have
it on an unsecured AWS database and now
there's 400 million addresses and phone
numbers out there all kinds of things
can happen and it takes having an actual
holistic process in place to to protect
that asset so that it doesn't become a
liability because it can very quickly
consumers want to know how their data is
being monetized I think everybody in
this room wants to know when you provide
your name and your age and your bank
account if that company is making money
off of that right they would say well if
the product is free then you're the
product well wouldn't you like to know
how your the product ain't Google makes
a lot of money a lot of these online
companies make a lot of money would you
like to know if you're being victimized
or if you're being given a cost benefit
that you're comfortable with
thanks to data privacy now that's
actually becoming part of the
conversation and Trust is not a one-time
transaction I mentioned this already
it's not the point at which you say I
accept and then they have no obligation
to you anymore they've agreed to things
and you've agreed to things as long as
they have your data until they can prove
they no longer do they have to support
you as a consumer because they have that
data and it's an asset that you've given
them for specific purposes power
dynamics are constantly changing so back
even in my college days I would have
thought about what would happen if I
left Facebook just because maybe I
didn't agree with what they were doing I
think about what that would have meant
that would have meant abandoning my
entire social group is a great power
dynamic there that that company could
have done whatever they wanted to do and
the harm to me to actually act
it would have been so significant that
that bar of what they can do got higher
and higher because I can't leave my
social group but now that things are
changing there's more tools there's more
technology there's more ways for us to
communicate for example just using
social media as the example those power
dynamics are starting to shift because
there's not one platform that has
control over everything
yes companies can purchase other
platforms and they end up getting some
but now there are other ways for us to
communicate so those power dynamic
shifting is giving consumers more muscle
to say hey when I cancel or when I
delete my account it means something to
you now it goes to your bottom line and
I'm not 1 out of 6 billion and it's
gonna be a drop in the bucket
now with power dynamic shifting we have
more control and data privacy laws help
amplify that a really important piece
that I want to make sure everybody
leaves with is that carrying the voice
of the consumer through your process
again it's not buzz term it's actually
something tangible that you can see as a
company so when you actually take
something that the customer needs and
you prioritize that over what you would
do for the competitive advantage of your
business you say fundamental right to
privacy these are these processes it's
not just for compliance it's not just
because I don't want to get fined it's
because I'm a consumer of this company
and this is how I would want to be
treated that's carrying the voice of the
consumer so when you carry those things
through it's actually incredibly
important because it echoes your
business's values that echoes who you
are as a company as well as who you are
as people and co-workers and then it
starts to give that visibility in
because in order to make it that
transparent in order to present that
awareness you actually have to give
consumers visibility into what you're
doing yes you're not going to give away
all your trade secrets but at the same
time by opening the window a little bit
and saying here's how we're using your
data here's what I'm doing with it this
is how I monetize it if I share it with
a third party why what do they have to
do do they have to protect it or am i
giving it to them with absolute immunity
these these are not trivial questions
they're incredibly important and they're
actually easy for companies to answer
and now that companies have started
answering those questions it's become
the price to come to the
and most importantly making it easy for
the consumers cannot be overstated there
are a lot of ways that you can try and
control privacy settings there are a lot
of really complex ways that you can try
and do it the harder it is for a
consumer to understand what those
settings are whether by default or what
they have control over the less they're
going to trust so you can create all
kinds of tools but unless it's easy for
me as a user and intuitive for me to go
in and say ok this is where I go if I
don't want you to sell my information to
a third party if I know how to go there
and it's a good user experience
I'm innately going to trust you as a
company because I believe that you're
thinking about me more than just how do
I get that dollar you're thinking about
how I keep them as a consumer going
forward even if there's not a dollar in
it for me that dollar was in it when I
got the dollar from you upfront now I'm
protecting that and showing you what it
means for you to be a consumer of this
company so contextual integrity hell and
even mom theorized this idea and it
sounds very simple but it's actually
incredibly powerful and continues to
accelerate as time moves forward privacy
is 100% context based I have a few nice
images here who would give me their
social security number yeah that's what
I thought so 20 years ago it probably
would have been the same amount of hands
a big old goose egg but maybe who would
have given me a retinal scan 10 years
ago I guarantee it's a nonzero amount
because we didn't know what you could do
with that right there weren't a lot of
technologies that used your retinal scan
now there are of course I get in to my
phone with with a facial recognition I
can get in to my phone with my
fingerprint these things are important
now but 10 15 20 years ago you probably
would have given it to me without
thinking about it because we didn't know
how those things could be used to harm
us so Helen needs a mom looks at this
from the perspective of informational
norms of appropriateness and flow so she
thinks about in the context of how is
this appropriate or not appropriate
based on cultural norms and social norms
and then how is that flowing how is that
distribute
across the community is it evenly
distributed is it unevenly distributed
is it something that is so difficult
that it that harm can't come to many
people until a lot of time has passed so
these ideas of appropriateness and flow
help guide whether or not we consider
something bad if someone were to come in
here and steal my wallet man cultural
norms say that's that's theft thankfully
laws say that's theft but if someone
were to come in here and look at me and
take a picture now I will give a shout
out to strange look because they give
the lanyard colors you get to say
whether you get a picture that's awesome
but if someone were to come in here and
take a picture of me what would what I
immediately say man I've been harmed
right now it's because of the context
around that what do I know
now can someone use that picture to get
into my phone maybe there is harm there
is someone going to post that online and
say that I'm a spokesperson for vaping
products okay this is really weird I
don't know why you'd choose me for that
but that's fine so so the context is
incredibly important and it changes over
time so privacy by design is exactly as
it sounds it is about taking privacy and
building it into your design process
that's what the words are thanks Jared
it's actually a little bit harder to do
in practice because a lot of folks don't
want to it slows down the agile
development process but this was
theorized by a Avakian
out of the Ontario Commissioner's Office
years and years ago and it still is
really highlighted today and of course
is article 25 of gdpr so it will
continue to be a pervasive topic the
central tenants of it are pretty simple
there are seven there's an eight there's
an asterisk next to it because I
selfishly added it but we'll get there
so first proactive not reactive when I
do something by design it is not after
I'm done designing it it's when it's
part of the process it has to be part of
the process
privacy is a default setting I hear a
lot of conversations around defaults
when I create an account are they going
to send me notifications by default
probably but do you think about that do
the companies think what would the user
want privacy has
be a default setting it can't be I'm
gonna sell your information until you go
to this hidden thing and tell me not to
anymore
that's a deceptive practice so it has to
be a default privacy embedded into
design kind of already talked about that
it has to be as you're planting the
plant not after the plants grown and
then you just sprinkle it with some
fertilizer it's positive some it's not
zero sown with data privacy we hear a
lot of talk about fines GPR they're
gonna they're gonna hit me with four
percent of my annual turnover yes that's
a huge amount but winds that actually
going to hit it's going to be in
litigation for years no it's it's
actually also the the court of public
opinion how is the stock gonna be
influenced how our consumer is going to
react to those things how our employees
going to react to those things when they
realize things are happening this way it
is not zero so full lifecycle protection
I've talked about how it's from the
point at which you request data so the
point at which you no longer have it it
has to be the full lifecycle and privacy
by design helps make sure that that was
built in from the get-go
visibility and transparency we've
already hit on pretty hard but it really
makes it easy for you to define for
consumers as well as for regulators how
you're handling privacy risk if you're
already talking about it you're already
defining it up front you don't have to
go back and say man are we doing data
retention oh man do I keep that for 10
years oh wow I use that in that product
I didn't oh that's in clear text these
are questions that shouldn't come up
after the facts it's before respect for
user privacy clearly by showing that you
care enough to build these things in
it's not just a compliance matter it's
about building consumer trust then
you're actually showing users that you
respect their privacy you respect their
rights not just what the law says you
have to do I respect that my consumers
are intelligent enough to have wants and
needs and I respect them enough to give
them and develop those options for them
to make those choices and then my
selfish ads sustainable and repeatable
I'm a broken record about this because I
really think it's the missing link when
you do this by design it becomes your
recurring process it's not a special wow
this is a really high risk data set
maybe I should do it this time
becomes your standard operating
procedure and it becomes so much easier
because you're not doing it just because
an audits coming up you're not doing it
just because a breach happened you're
doing it because it's it's part of what
your core business processes are and
then just one quick relationship that
we've seen governance and data
optimization maturity they always go
hand-in-hand I am yet to see a client or
a company in which the governance is
incredibly mature but the optimization
of their data and organization of that
data is not mature they tend to go hand
in hand because in order to govern and
in order to use things in an optimized
manner you actually have to understand
what you have where it is who has access
how you're using it how you're holding
it and how long you're holding it if you
can answer that long list of questions
then your ability to optimize that data
and use it to its fullest extent is more
likely we cannot practice privacy by
design in retrospect I've seen so many
companies try you just can't privacy by
design has to be up front if you try and
do it in Reverse not only is it gonna be
ten times more expensive it's gonna be
ten times more difficult because you're
trying to go back into Prior processes
and figure out and I wasn't looking for
this who's gonna know if I do this if
you define these things upfront you've
already got them documented you already
have sni's who are thinking about it you
already have your products define to be
able to handle these if you realize that
you're not doing something well we're
doing this and the other product so it's
easy for us to figure out what the fixes
we're not doing something for the first
time because someone came knocked on the
door and said what's your data retention
right now so I really hope that one big
takeaway from this is the role that
developers analysts and architects play
because right now the current state of
privacy is not being guided by the folks
in this room and that's a problem for me
that's a big problem for me the legal
department should not be telling you
what you need to build the legal
department should be confirming for you
that what you're building is good and
then if it's not helping you to figure
that out I spend a lot of my days trying
to
bridge the gap between legal and between
the technical side which basically just
speak Latin and take Latin maybe it
doesn't go comfortably so bridging that
gap between them helps take that
responsibility in that burden and move
it over to the right people what are
some things that are being done today
because privacy is impacting
organizations regardless of their size
there are a lot of different approaches
none of them are one-size-fits-all of
course you have centralized privacy
offices that are really trying to govern
things at a holistic enterprise level
and that's great P IAS or DP IAS these
are privacy impact assessments or data
protection impact assessments that's
having these compliance folks who
understand the laws going in and saying
I'm gonna look at your process and look
at what data you use and I'm gonna try
and define what risk you have but again
that's generally done by another party
not by the developers who are getting
ready to build something data
minimization and masking so if you don't
need something don't take it I can't
stress that enough and I've actually had
people look at me and go no no I ran it
by legal they're good with it
so would you be willing to show me a
lawyer that says yes please take social
security numbers when you have no
reasonable reasonable business purpose
to do so that's never gonna happen
thankfully that's never gonna happen at
least not out loud we've got bias
detection so looking at things on the
back end how am i treating different
populations am i under representing over
representing how can I detect that it's
generally retrospective and implement
implementation right now but it's
happening secure processing you'll hear
things about homomorphic encryption
you'll hear things about differential
privacy I'll talk briefly about in a bit
there are new things coming out we are
looking at it the right way protection
is definitely part of privacy but it's
not the only piece of privacy legal and
the regulators I just sounded like an
awesome name for a band
so these parties are still really owning
a lot of these things when you go in a
new law comes out you have lawyers
coming to you and saying okay we got to
do it for this process we
do it for that product oh yeah we got
some people we got some employees that
are over there in that jurisdiction okay
we got to do it for that one to go and
you say how am I supposed to do that not
my job I'm just supposed to tell you
what to do not how to do it and then
there's just a ball that gets dropped
right there so there's a lot of that
happening right now and then trust
centers so I actually had the privilege
to cooperate on some work here with
trust centers colleague of mine is doing
a lot of work with Cisco and that's the
picture you see to the right creating
data sheets and data maps so it's
starting to take data flows and take
them down from a really specific network
topology level and bringing it down to a
digestible for your average consumer to
be able to to understand and know how
that impacts that risk where does my PII
go where does it terminate where does my
non PII go these sorts of things are
important and they're useful
there is no panacea there is not I wish
there were that'd be great
it might not be for job security but
it's it would be great for businesses
everywhere but the really important
thing to think about is that companies
are breaking new ground and as they
break new ground they're building an
inventory of tools that we can use and
the more tools and the more processes
that you put in place to guard different
ways the better off consumers will be
we'll talk about those so getting to
machine learning and AI it's incredibly
unique for reasons that I'm sure
everyone is here in this room for it it
might be simple for me to say Jared can
you define for me the logic and whether
or not that person gets an email it's
probably pretty simple right it's just a
rule but if I say hey so that machine
learning algorithm can you define
exactly how it gave me that upper and
lower bound why did that person not get
covered in insurance because that was
their risk score now we're getting a
little dicey ER and one I don't know if
I can't answer that in two am I allowed
to answer that can I can I peel back the
curtain and show people that information
how would I even do that I don't I what
decision tree in this random forest
algorithm made that decision that that
kicked it over the edge and said that
persons not insurable these are really
difficult questions to answer
so talked about the complexity and
algorithmic in lot
chuckle methods the moment of decision
making is very very important for
regulators but it's also one of the
hardest things to pinpoint when it comes
to detailed and an in-depth machine
learning and deep learning so is much
easier said than done
algorithm algorithmic fairness so the
FTC Act section 5 talks about unfair and
deceptive acts but it doesn't look at it
through the context of my machine
learning model made that choice I didn't
look at that guy and see oh man I hate
his t-shirt I don't want to cover him
it's not something like that it's not
that easy so identifying what was unfair
what was deceptive can be an incredibly
difficult process and even more
incredibly difficult to prosecute and
then distinct risks between algorithmic
fairness and the use of algorithms so
just because my algorithm might be fair
it might not mistreat an under
representative population maybe the
person who gets the results does
something with that and they interpret
the output in a different way than was
intended so you've got two sides to bias
you've got the bias and the algorithm
and you've got the bias in the output of
that algorithm and the use of that
algorithm and bias omission before it
can be unintentional it can be
intentional sometimes we think we know
domain knowledge very well and we encode
things that may have had our own
personal bias nested in it maybe I think
guys named Jared aren't worth loans I
don't know maybe I even had bad
experiences with guys that have the same
name as me and I just don't want that
guy to get a loan anymore wouldn't be
great for me but it also brings in a
really weird bias that shouldn't be
there but even if I have the best of
intentions man most the people I know
named Jared they do not pay their loans
back that's not great anecdotal evidence
that's real cute but then on top of that
with machine learning and AI what's
learning from its self it's gonna
perpetuate that by systemically
so it might have just been one person
said something and made a decision but
then it got perpetuated as part of that
model going forward and might not be
silly your name is Jared but it might be
something that's much more harmful and
then that balance between competitive
advantage and transparency we want to
tell consumers what's happening to the
that we can but we also can't peel back
everything because then we're going to
let our competitors know exactly what
logic we're using so it's a really
really tight balance between those two
things so the role of developers and
engineers domain knowledge is critical
when I've seen legal departments or
privacy offices try and define risk they
often say can I get the people who built
the product in the room because I can
read the law but I don't know how they
coded it I don't know what logic is
going into it and that's a really
important thing it's not the legal
departments job to know that but it's
incredibly important no one is going to
be able to give the input that you as
engineers and developers can because you
know the logic of what you're building
no one will know you're thinking like
you can and that sounds so silly but
when you think about trying to diagnose
privacy risk in retrospect going back
and getting in the head of the developer
who built that algorithm it's so
difficult let alone trying to go back to
the developer and say what were you
thinking when you did that why did you
do that that way on a 26 hour work day
and a lot of coffee I have no idea so so
doing these upfront through design is
incredibly important and having it be
the people that are in this room who do
those things who can actually answer
those questions innately with the domain
knowledge is incredibly important and
then building new methods who's gonna
build them find something that works
great people in this room are gonna
build them so I can't impress upon you
enough the importance of developers and
engineers here so I'm gonna talk real
briefly about some methods for this so
I'm not going to be able to cover
everything or even to the level of
degree that I'd like to but I wanted to
really highlight how you can look at
risk from different perspectives
you've got seeking out risk in your data
so I can look at the data and I can try
and figure out where identifiability
becomes easier talk about those a little
bit
seeking out risk and processing I can
either look for bias in my algorithms or
maybe I can look at how I release that
information and an eighth differential
privacy that list could be pages in
pages long but you guys don't have a
pillow enough for that one so we're
gonna we're gonna try and go through
those quickly and then seeking out risk
and development this one is one I'm
really passionate about because I think
this is how you get to the by design
this is where you get the qualitative
and the quantitative upfront and you
define it you document it so that then I
don't need to go into your head later I
know what you were thinking I know what
data is being used I know what the logic
is I know what the outcomes are so we'll
talk a little bit about some methods for
that so real quickly in order to do the
few risk in your data approaches wanted
to look at the different types of data
that we deal with so of course you've
got your PII your personal I personally
identifiable information full name
social security number I have that I
know who you are those are very simple
then you've got your quasi identifiable
information in orange they're your age
your gender your zip code your age
doesn't give me who you are but if I get
your age and your gender and your zip
and maybe a couple other things I can
probably get pretty close to you maybe
one out of five and once we're at one
out of five you probably don't feel safe
anymore
so once you're getting there you call it
quasi identifiable I can combine it with
other things to get to you non
identifiable information
I will caveat this by saying it depends
on the data set so we've got country
here let's just imagine that this is a
data set of a thousand people from the
US it's not identifiable there's nothing
different about this data set yes if
there was one person who was from Laos
and I knew that they worked at this
company where the data set was then
maybe it fits and then for sensitive
information be it for other regulatory
issues because of Health because legal
or religious these are things that
really need to be protected so different
methods here so anonymity diversity and
closeness they're all very
interconnected they all built off of one
another none of them are perfect they're
all labor-intensive but there ways to
look at risk in your data and try and
cleanse it a little bit so that you can
at least reduce the the attack surface
so to speak so Kay anonymity is saying I
want to make sure that my data set has
at least K records of a certain group I
don't want this data set to have such a
rare medical condition that only one
person in the world has it and if I show
that medical condition I know exactly
who that person is that's an obscure
example but it really looks at how you
need to make sure that there is at least
enough of a representative population
that you're not giving a record
that releasing that data doesn't become
easily identifiable for a person you can
do that through suppressing data if you
find out fields or that way you can do
it through grouping and generalization
so instead of saying a hundred and two
years old
you can just take greater than 80 years
old you can group things together to
reduce that risk but there are still
weaknesses homogeneity attacks
background knowledge attacks knowing
about the data income diversity so l
diversity it's an extension of this it
really says look at the equivalence
groups amongst my quasi identifiable
information if I group all the people
with the same age gender and zip code
how different are they do I have many of
them do I have two of them do I have 20
of them with this one medical condition
one with the other medical condition
what is the diversity of looking like
maybe I need to remove records because
someone's privacy is going to be at risk
it would be the same basic process but
you get you get to work against
attribute inference there and weaknesses
so it's very complex you're gonna have
to look at every single group of qi and
then compare it to your other
information which can be very difficult
and then moving to closeness which is
again and a further extension of this
it's looking at how does the
distribution of my data
look versus the global distribution so
if I cleanse my data throughout I say
I'm just gonna take out everyone that's
female well great the global
distribution of other identifiable or
sensitive variables probably just
changed because I just completely
changed the population so now someone
who wants to look at that data set can
now attack it know you've introduced
some change here's how it is I can
reverse engineer it so these are not
perfect but they help build up the wall
so now a couple ways to actually look at
model prediction risk so adversarial
training is one this is actually a way
of saying let's combine competing tasks
say I've got something I want to predict
Y and then something I don't want to be
used Z let's say I don't want to
discriminate based on race I can make
race this thing that I don't want to
predict I want my model to ignore it I
want my model to look for when I'm
trying and stop adversarial training is
a way for us to do this so you can
actually prevent the recovery of that
sensitive
a tribute because as you go and predict
things there's actually a negative
gradient being provided back as a signal
through your algorithm that says I'm
gonna look for this and I'm gonna not
decide based on it even if I see a
correlation here so it really in the
contrapositive will also prevent someone
from saying oh there's a lack of this z
thing here so that my model must not be
dependent upon it so I highly recommend
for examples of code here I'd love to
walk through every line but AI fairness
360 it's fantastic it looks at
adversarial training and so much more in
terms of different algorithms for
seeking out bias but this is just one
popular example dynamic of sampling
through VA e so VA e referring to
variational autoencoders this one is
actually great because it doesn't
require you to know what those sensitive
attributes are what's happening here is
that by using this encoder it's actually
looking for latent representations in
what your model is defining as it trains
so then as its training it can look and
see oh wow it's really pinging on race
here I'm gonna I'm gonna pump data back
in to tell it to stop looking at that or
to look at it less to weight it less so
I can actually have my model train
itself to look for things that it's
impinging on and stop doing it so much
so that's really interesting because you
don't have to define what that column is
it's gonna look and see where the latent
representations are so it really
prevents the amplification of bias
because once you ping on that field you
can ping on it again and again and again
and then the model learns from that and
it keeps doing it so if you want to stop
doing that this is one way to approach
that developed by a team at MIT in
Harvard
it's actually very cutting-edge the only
code that you'll find for it is actually
in some MIT deep learning labs I highly
encourage you go out got a link here in
the presentation happy to provide to
anyone it is open source
finally differential privacy so really
was formalized mathematically by Cynthia
dork and a team of researchers to
understand how I create epsilon
differential privacy what the heck does
that mean that means how do I get some
kind of certainty that you can't
identify an individual
well how am I gonna do that well I'm
gonna pump random noise into what I give
you back so let's say you come to me and
you say I'm gonna put in an epsilon
value of 0.25 and I want to know what
the mean grade is for girls between 14
and 16 in Missouri okay
well I don't need to give you the data
set of all those protected folks I can
actually pump some random noise in there
and it's going to be controlled so I
know exactly how much noise I'm putting
in there so that I can give you a useful
upper and lower bound so you don't
actually have to see all that data you
actually ask a question you have a
limited amount of queries you can send
so you can't just brute force attack it
but I can give you an answer back that
is both statistically useful and doesn't
give you information about individuals
so I can learn about a population in
generalities in a way that's
statistically useful but I don't have to
know that jared is a male who lives in
st. Louis I don't have to know those
things because I can learn in other ways
so there is some great code Google
really is leading the way in this they
actually released an open-sourced some
of their differential privacy code
highly recommend you go and look at it
it's incredibly intuitive very
insightful and it's and it's really
spreading that message that the more we
do this the more this becomes standard
operating procedure the better off
consumers will be so now we're getting
into the qualitative piece first I'm
going to talk about model cards for
model reporting model cards is something
that was created by researchers at
Google and in tandem with University of
Toronto it's a mechanism for gaining
insight into the models as they're being
designed and then as they're being
tested so it looks at things like model
details what's the intended use what are
the factors the metrics the ethical
considerations the caveats and
recommendations to those things so you
can actually get a profile of what's
happening in that model instead of just
saying here's a model that's in this
folder over here we run it every week
and I give some data to this group who
then processes it and makes decisions we
can actually have this so that when
auditors come and say what is this model
doing how is it doing it we already have
that we can actually provide this
context
don't have to go back into the mind of
the developer you can do that now and
then lastly multi-dimensional privacy
analytic so this was created by Deirdre
Mulligan and a team of researchers at
out of UC Berkeley and I love this as an
add-on to model cards because what it
actually does is it takes the
qualitative data and makes it important
it breaks out privacy into different
dimensions so you can think about it as
what's what's the theory behind it what
is what is the privacy that's being
protected who is being protected why by
what are they being protected and then
you can think about harm ultimately this
is about quantifying harm how do I
figure out where it is and how do I help
prevent it so by mashing together model
reporting cards and the privacy analytic
you can get both a qualitative and a
quantitative look at what you're doing
which is incredibly important so if you
think about this we've talked about a
lot of different methods I want you to
see this as a life cycle and if I could
make this circular with as many words I
would have because it really needs to be
iterative just like the agile
development process is you need to be
able to do this in a way that's not
gonna take you six hours every week it
has to be something you can do during
story grooming or during a retro it has
to be something that you can answer
quickly and efficiently without slowing
you down
so you prioritize the risk assessments
you implement the privacy risk
mitigation in your data you look at
where risk resides in your data you
utilize the tools that we've talked
about to root out bias or to minimize
the amount of information that you share
in answering queries you get key
feedback from your stakeholders talk to
the business talk to ml knowledgeable
folks talk to engineers who actually
built the application that is using that
algorithm so that they understand what
decisions are being made and how and
when and then visualize that potential
harm and model it you model it using
these cards you look at it from both a
qualitative and a quantitative
perspective it's going to be incredibly
powerful and you're going to be able to
have a very clear message not just for
regulators but for consumers and how you
address these things so this is just a
really a lot of words for us to
re-explain that but the piece I want to
get through is that the folk
this room are the ones best suited to do
this right now they're being done by
folks who need your help and it has to
involve developers engineers and data
scientists because without that we don't
get the kind of insights into what we're
thinking when we define these algorithms
or what we're thinking when we include
this data and exclude that data it's
incredibly important for us to keep this
context because without that context we
can't clearly define the risk thank you
very much
[Applause]